An important use case for computer vision
and machine learning is self driving cars.
In this course, Akshay will teach you how to
implement many techniques related to perception
of self driving cars, and engineers am SEC
sec. Welcome to this course on perception
for self driving cars. In this course, we
will go over a number of different projects
that are related to the perception module of
the self driving car. This course is meant
for an intermediate level of audience, you are
required to know the basic concepts of Python,
as well as some basic concepts regarding
deep learning. This course is meant for you
if you are looking to get into the field of
self driving cars, or if you are interested
to do projects that are related to computer
vision using deep learning. Before starting,
if you like the content of this course, you can
also check out my channel robotics with Akshay
where I post videos related to robotics and
artificial intelligence. So now let's get started.
Our first project would be road segmentation. In
this project, we will be doing segmentation of
road images using a deep learning technique called
fully convolutional networks. In the next project,
we will be doing 2d object detection on various
different traffic scenarios using a deep learning
technique called the Yolo algorithm. Next,
we will be tracking those object detections
using a technique called Deep sought. After we
are done with the 2d part in these three projects,
we will be moving on to the 3d part, we will
start our 3d part with 3d data visualization
where we will visualize camera images and
LIDAR data. Next, we will be discussing
multi task learning based on two tasks depth
estimation and semantic segmentation. Then
we are going to move on to 3d object detection.
Then move on to our final project the bird's eye
view visualization using an advanced computer
vision technique called transformers, all the
data set and the core notebooks are provided,
so that you can follow along with this course.
Alright, so what is the road segmentation
problem, you would say, indoor segmentation
given an input image, we are required to identify
where are the roads present in this image.
Now we as humans can see that road is present
right over here in somewhat in the middle of the
image. So what we are required is to output
an image something that looks like this.
Now here, we have imaged the road
that is present in that image.
Now, we aren't going to exactly output this, but
what we require is that we somehow mark this road
in a separate image. One way to do that would
be to output a black and white image where white
represents wherever the old is present, and zero
or black represents the other background in that
image. Let's have a look at another image as well.
Now this is another road image that we can see
now. Now as humans, it is easy to see
where is the road present in this image.
For a computer, what it would see is something
like this. So the computer has to output a
segmentation mask that looks something like this.
Now these two images that you're seeing over here,
are part of the GT road data set. Now a data
set is a collection of such input images
and desired output images, which we use to
baseline or check how our model is performing.
If our model is able to perform well on these
images, we can be kind of sure that they are going
to perform well in real world as well. But there
are some complications that are required as well.
Okay, so by now you would have understood what is
the problem of road segmentation and the data set
that we're working on, which is the kitty robot
data set. Now for this task of road segmentation,
there exists a number of computer vision
techniques that we can apply. The older computer
vision techniques required us the programmers to
actually hard code the different values in order
to segment the road that is present in the image.
Now this technique is prone to a lot of errors and
usually doesn't generalize very good. Like this
technique would work for one image very good but
would completely fail for another image. For
instance, if we develop a technique to segment
a road on an image, then even a little shadow
on the road would completely ruin our parameter
tuning and we will require to tune the parameters
again. Then with the advent of deep learning,
we got rid of such high grafting techniques where
in the computer would automatically learn these
parameters given a diverse set of data. So, one
such technique that we are going to discuss today
is fully convolutional networks. Now, fully
convolutional networks were one of the first
techniques that introduced their method of
segmentation end to end. What I mean by end to end
is that given an input image, if we feed the input
image to an FCN model, it will directly output the
segmentation that it is trained for, no other pre
processing or post processing would be required
on that image as such. Now, we are applying the
fully convolutional network technique on the road
segmentation task, which is we can say a subset of
the segmentation task as well. So how the complete
picture looks like is that we have an image input
image that has a road present in it, we pass that
input image to the FCN model that we have, and
towards the output, we get a 01 image binary
image where one is present wherever the lane
was present, or the road was present. Otherwise,
we have zero in the complete image. Now, in
order to understand fully convolutional networks,
we first need to understand an image operation
called up sampling. So let's have a look at that.
So in simple words, up sampling is an operation
where we increase the size of a given input. For
instance, if we are given an image like this, a
two cross two image, then upsampling to x is going
to double the height and the width, therefore,
we will be having four cross four output,
the complete problem of of sampling is we need
to decide what are going to be the values in this
whole cross code metrics when we would be given
the values in this to cross to given metrics.
So there exists a number of techniques that we
can employ, let's discuss a few of them first, the
first technique for up sampling we have is called
bed of nails, what we do in bed of nails, whatever
the values present in this matrix, we are going
to assign that value to this block over here.
So the three values that are related to this block
which are 123, these three blocks are assigned
a value of zero. Similarly from this block, we
can take a value and we can assign it over here,
the rest three related values are assigned zero,
these, which are these three. Similarly, we do the
same thing for these two cell values as well. Now
this is a really simplistic technique where we are
going to have a lot of zeros in our output image,
a better method than this is the nearest neighbor
method. In nearest neighbor method, what we do
is we take the value that is present over here,
and in all the four related cells to this
cell, we assign the same value. For instance,
if we have one over here, we are going to assign
the value of one to all the four blocks over here.
Similarly, if we have a value of two over here,
then we're going to assign the value of two
to these four blocks here. And we do this
similarly for the complete metrics over here.
Now, an even better method than nearest neighbor
is called interpolation. Now, interpolation is
more like an average finding technique where we
assign values based on a weighted average, how
we do that, in interpolation, we try to work our
way backwards, if we want to calculate the value
of this cell over here, then we approximately try
to overlap this matrix with this matrix, what we
are going to see is that this block is going to
lie somewhere over here. Now this cell over here
is close to four values in this matrix, which are
all the four values over here. Now based on the
distance from these four values, we are going to
assign an average value to this cell over here.
Similarly, we are going to do this for this cell
as well, this is going to lie somewhere over here,
and average value will be assigned to this cell
based on the distance from the four cells that are
present over here. Likewise, if we want to assign
the value of this cell over here, then this cell
is going to lie somewhere over here. Now, we are
going to take the average of these two cells only
because these are the nearest neighbors present to
this cell. So this is how the interpolation method
works. Now interpolation method is one of the best
technique that we could apply, but there exists
an even better technique that we can apply
as well, which is transposed convolutions.
In all the techniques that we discussed before, we
were assigning the values based on some heuristic
that we hardcourt. Instead in transpose
convolution, we assign the values based on
a learnable weight filter, we define a filter
of some size with some random weight values.
We then use those weight values to assign the
value of All these cells that are present in
this matrix and pass this to the network, when the
network is going to do a backpropagation, we are
going to back propagate the loss of the weights
of those filter as well and they are going to be
learned as well. For the purpose of this project,
I tried two methods which were interpolation
and transposed convolutions, from what I saw
transpose convolutions did not work very well.
But the interpolation method worked really well
for our case. Now, since we have understood what
the upsampling operation is all about. So
let's now discuss the architecture of the
fully convolutional network. So for the fully
convolutional network, we require a backbone
network, which is an image classification network
called VGG. Net. Now, what is image classification
and what is VGG net? Now image classification is
a problem where we are given an input image and
we are required to decide what is present in that
image. Or we can say the computer is required to
decide what is present in that image. Now, before
doing anything, we already define the classes
before sending an input image. For instance, if
in our image, we know that there are going to be
three entities that are present, airplane bicycle
and a person, then we are going to assign a value
zero to the airplane, one to the bicycle and to
to the person. Then we pass an image through the
image classification network, and it outputs 01
Or two, representing what it saw in the image.
Now, image classification is kind of a solved
problem where we have models which give very
good results on some baseline datasets. One
such good network is VGG. Net. Now since VGG,
network takes in an image input and outputs a
single number output, we need to convert it for
our use case, which is the segmentation problem.
In the segmentation problem, the input is an image
and the output is also an image that is of the
same dimensions. So let's see the changes that
we require to make to this VGG net in order to
output such images. Now, VGG network is composed
of a number of convolutional blocks, it's placed
sequentially to each other. Each convolution block
consists of two convolutional layers, followed by
a max pooling layer. Now what we do is we extract
the output of last three convolutional blocks,
which are pool three, pool four and pool five.
So what we do first, we upsample, this pool five
times two, so we have an bigger image over here,
then we add this output to the output of
pool four, then what we get over here,
we again upsample, this output two times to
get an output over here. And finally again,
add this pool three layer, which then we get the
output over here. Finally, we upsample this output
eight times. And the final output that we get
is the segmentation mask that we require. Now,
this long sequence is what constitutes the FCN
architecture, or particularly this is the FCN
eight architecture. There exist to other FCN
architectures as well FCN 32, and FCN 16. What
we do in FCN 32, we don't go through all these
operations that we have done over here, instead,
we simply upsample, this pool five layer 32
times and we get the output in FCN 16, we again,
don't do all these operations, we simply go to
this step over here where we calculate the sum
till pool four, and then we assemble it 16 times
to get the output since we are performing all the
operations that are present over here, and finally
upsample eight times therefore, this architecture
is called FCN eight. In one way, we can say that
FCN eight is a combination of FCN 32 and FCN 16.
What this means is that FCN 32 identifies coarser
structures in the image FCN 16 identifies more
finer structures in the image and FCN eight
even more finer structures in the image
using these addition operations that we have over
here we are combining the knowledge of these three
networks to get the final output. Now these are
the complete details of the architecture and how
to architecture is somewhat working on the
inside. Alright, so now our discussion for this is
complete. Now let's have a look at how this model
was implemented and what are the different results
that we got. So let's have a look at that the
data set and the code both are present on Kaggle.
The link for both of these is in the description
you can have a look at them as well. Okay. So
this is the implementation First we define
an input layer with a parameter input shape.
Now input shape is a tuple that contains image
size, image size, common number of channels, image
size we have set over here is 128, cross 128,
and number of channels is three the RGB channels
That way define the VGG network, but that is VGG
16. TensorFlow or Kara's already provides us with
the implementation of VGG 16, which is pre trained
on the image net data set. Then we extract these
three blocks, which are the pool three, pool
four and pull five layers. For the first step,
we have sample two times that we can see over
here, the tool five layer, then we add the sub
sample layer to the pool for and we apply a one
cross one convolution over here, as you can see,
now this convolution is more like a placeholder
to get the dimensions in the right size,
as such, using them or not using them doesn't
have a big impact on the performance as such.
Then we apply the second up sampling the second
two acts of sampling and add that upsampled
layer with the pool three layer, again, we
apply a convolution to D which is again as
kind of a placeholder overhead. Finally, for the
output, we calculate the upsampling eight times
this final convolution is a required one. Now
this n classes is said to be one over here,
this is done because we want to set the output
of the network to be a single channel image.
Now that single channel is going to contain zero
and one as we discussed before, one is going to
be the mask where the road is present and zero
otherwise. We also apply a sigmoid activation
over here in order to get the final values
between zero and one. And then we return the
model with the inputs and outputs as such set
and we have named the model FCN eight likewise
now let's have a look at the results that
we got his images were held out from the
model and the model is seeing them from
for the first time this is a second image.
Now as we can see the model is working really
well. Now let's apply some changes to the baseline
network that we have and see how the results
change. Now this is one change that we do. Instead
of the add function we are using the concatenate
function over here in adding what we do is we
add the corresponding values that are present in
the matrix of two images. However in concatenate,
we just add that image to the back of the image
and increase the number of channels of the input.
So now let's see what are the results after
we apply this concatenate instead of ad?
So we can see that concatenate is also
performing good, but add is a little
better than this concatenate function. Now, let's
change that upsampling today with convolutional
2d transpose, which we can see over here,
so instead of upsampling, here we are using
transpose convolution where we are going
to learn the weights of upsampling as well.
And we are using the add function over here.
So let's see how the results for this look like
So we can clearly see that transpose
convolution is not getting that good of results,
although it has learned the task,
but the output is kind of pixelated,
and doesn't really look good
on the segmentation as well.
Alright, so these are the results of the
network and some of its extensions as well.
So, before discussing what is to do object
detection problem, let us first see,
what is the data set that is provided to us in
this project. So, Lyft is a self driving cars
company that develops self driving car software.
In order to further the research in self driving
cars. Lyft announced two competitions that were
held previously, these two competitions were
3d object detection and motion prediction,
these two are separate. The data set that
we're going to use for this project is the one
from the left 3d object detection challenge.
So what was given in the
object detection challenge.
So, what Lyft did is it drove a self driving car
around the streets of Palo Alto, and they recorded
the camera data as well as the LIDAR sensor
data. Now, Lidar is a sensor that works on the
principle of reflection of laser lights and lasers
starting from the sensor goes and hits an obstacle
returns back to the sensor and the sensor detects
the distance of that object. So in this data set,
we are given the camera data as well
as the LIDAR data or the same trip.
As we can see, these are some sample pictures.
So this is one back image. As we can see,
we have certain cars over here we have the front
image, we have certain cars over here as well.
Now we can compare the LIDAR data with the camera
data. So we saw our car is localized at this
cross and we can see that there is one car that
is present over here that is trying to enter the
lane besides us as we can see we also have a car
over here and we can also see that we have two
cars behind our car which are present over here.
These blue bounding boxes represent pedestrians
so we also have front left image and
right image back right image and back
left image we can also visualize the data
in a video format so let's play this video
similarly, we can also visualize the LIDAR
data in a video format let's play this video
so, the code for this data visualization
will be present in the description box below.
We are specifically going to work
on the camera images as such.
So now let us discuss what is this object
detection problem and what is the difference
between 2d and 3d object detection. So in object
detection, the complete problem is framed as such.
That in a given image, we are required to find
the location of an object present in that image
as well as also tell what is that object. For
instance, in this example, we can see over here,
there is one dog that is present and there are two
cats. So given this image, we need to output where
is the dog present in the form of bounding box
and where are the cats present. Now in a 2d object
detection case, we would be given a 2d image and
we are required to give the bounding boxes in 2d.
However, in 3d object detection, apart from a
2d image, we would also be given some other data
representation as well. Using that image and
the additional data, we are required to return
a 3d bounding box of that object along with
its label. A very good example is in the 3d
object detection data as well. As we can see,
we are given 3d bounding boxes of the various
cars in this image. And we are also given
an additional data which is the LIDAR data
And we can also see that we are predicting
pedestrians as well as well as the cars. So
one cool thing that we can also notice is that we
are also able to detect objects that are included
in the given image. How we are able to
do that is because of the additional data
that is provided by the LIDAR. Alright, so
this is all for 3d and 2d object detection.
In this video, we are only going to focus on
2d object detection. So we are going to run
an algorithm on these given images and predict 2d
bounding boxes. So let's discuss that algorithm
in detail. As you may have seen in object
detection, we have to localize the object
as well as tell what that object is. Now in case
of self driving cars, as we can see over here,
if we are given two cars, then we also need to
find the position of those two cars as well as
decide are the cars are the pedestrians are their
bicycles, and so on. Now, the algorithm that we're
going to discuss for 2d object detection is
yellow, y O L O. And this stands for view only
local ones. Now giving an overall picture, we can
divide the Yolo algorithm into three stages, which
are the anchor boxes, the intersection over union
and the bounding box predictions. So how does this
work? Now YOLO is also a deep learning technique
that we use for object detection. In this we
are given an input image, we pass this input
image through a convolutional neural network.
And as an output, we get another metrics. Usually,
for the Yolo algorithm, this metric size is taken
to be 19 Cross 19. What does this input to output
mapping represent? If we consider this matrix as a
19 cross 19 matrix, if we take our input image
as such, and overlap this 1919 matrix over it,
then the 19 cross 19 boxes that we can see over
our image, all those individual boxes are going
to tell what is present in that box. It can either
be a car, a truck, or even a motorcycle. And it
is also possible that there is nothing useful
present in that particular box. For instance,
in our case, it would be we can say Road, for each
cell, we are going to have this vector in place,
this thing can also be visualized as this matrix
is actually a volume. So 19 Cross 19 Are the
width and the height of this matrix. And in the
depth perspective, we have this complete vector.
Now let's see what this vector describes.
This vector that we discussed, describes the
information that is present in that particular
cell, the PC value is going to tell whether
something interesting is present in that cell or
not, is something interesting is not present in
that cell, then the other values are just going
to be undefined, or we are not going to consider
them in the calculations as such. If we assume
that PC is one and there is something interesting
present in that cell, then x and y are going
to describe the position of the center of that
object with respect to a given cell. So x and y
are going to tell if we start from this upper left
corner of this cell, how much we need to go right
and how much we need to go down in order to reach
the midpoint of that object, W and H describe
the width and height again with respect to that
cell. Now these C one C two c three variables
describe what object is present in that cell.
For instance, if we have three objects, then one
of these three is going to be one, the other ones
are going to be zero. If we consider that we have
four objects in our consideration, then we're
going to have four variables over here c one,
c two, C three and C four. Now we can see what
is going to be present in the output. Some of the
output cells, as we can see there, red over here,
are going to describe that something special is
present in that particular cell. So the output
over here gives us what the object is going to
be and what is going to be the bounding box of
that particular object. One certain example is we
can see over here for this particular car, we can
see that there are multiple bounding boxes that
have been generated by this output. And in order
to differentiate I have also drawn one car in the
corner over here as well, that also has multiple
bounding boxes describing it. Along with these
bounding boxes and the labels, we also compute
a probability. This probability also describes how
much confident our our bounding box predictions.
For instance, this bounding box over here, the
outer one can have a lower probability. However,
the one that is inside is going to have a higher
probability. So this is how one part the bounding
box prediction part of Ulo works. In order to
separate these bounding boxes and get a single
bounding box for each object, we use intersection
over union. And this technique of getting a single
bounding box and separating different bounding
boxes is called non maximum suppression.
Okay. So first let us see what is intersection
over union or we can say I owe you. So,
IOU is used to compute how much are two bounding
boxes different, you will be able to see that
in its mathematical description. So if we have
two bounding boxes as we have given over here,
we first calculate their intersection and divide
that by their union. So, this gives us a measure
of how two bounding boxes are similar to
each other. So, we can use IOU to separate
the bounding boxes of two different objects.
For instance, these two, we calculate the value
of the bounding boxes with respect to the maximum
probability bounding box. So, what this means,
if we consider again that the inside bounding box
has the highest probability, and we calculate the
IOU score for the other four bounding boxes with
respect to this maximum probability bounding box,
we can see that these two bounding boxes are going
to have a very high IOU value. Since they have
a very high IOU value, this means that they are
actually representing the same object. Therefore,
we discard these other two bounding boxes of these
two other bounding boxes, they have a very low IOU
value, this depicts that they represent some other
object, and we are going to apply the non maximum
suppression separately on these bounding boxes.
And this is how the intersection over union part
of you know works, or there can be a scenario
in which a single cell over here represents
multiple different objects. One small example
would be two cars that are parked side by side.
So, in one of these cells, we are going to
capture both of those guys simultaneously.
In order to deal with that problem,
we use this concept of anchor boxes,
these anchor boxes represent a rough shape for the
different objects that are going to be present in
our image. These anchor boxes can be designed
by us humans, or it can be decided by another
machine learning algorithm as well. So how does
this anchor box help in detection of multiple
objects, so each anchor box describes what shape
of the object they are looking for. For instance,
this anchor box is looking for a square object.
This anchor box is looking for a rectangular
object with a greater height than width. And
this anchor box is looking for an object which is
greater in width, but less in height, each anchor
box is going to predict a certain specific object,
and how this is going to change our output. For
each cell, instead of having this single vector,
we are going to extend this vector in our case
three times since we have three anchor boxes,
this enables us to predict multiple objects
that will be present in a single cell. So,
all these techniques combined give us the Yolo
algorithm YOLO algorithm is a really fast and
accurate object detection technique, which makes
it extremely useful for perception in self driving
cars, there is a lot of work that has been done
on this YOLO algorithm too much so that that we
have multiple variants of YOLO algorithm with each
variant of the Yolo algorithm, there has been an
improvement in the speed as well as the accuracy.
Okay, so now let's see this YOLO algorithm in
action YOLO is a very complex algorithm that
would take quite a lot of time to develop. Hence,
it is neither feasible nor an intelligent
way that we implement your law from scratch.
Hence, we are going to use this Charis YOLO v3
implementation provided by experience or apologies
if I pronounced that incorrectly. This is an
open source implementation, I would provide the
link to the repository in the description section
below. This is the notebook that we have the link
for this notebook would also be present in the
description section below. Since there is nothing
much to discuss with respect to implementation, we
will directly get to the results that we have on
this dataset. So I have zoomed into show the image
is better as we can see the camera was attached on
a car so we are also detecting our portion of the
car as well. We are detecting other cars as well.
However, we can see that this bus is getting
detected as a truck. We have predictions on
car as well over here. Cars over here. Ours so we
can see we also have one truck detection over Here
we have the detection of a bus over here as well.
And we also have a truck that is much behind
Alright, so these were the results that we got
on running the Yolo v3 algorithm on the left
3d object detection data set. Now, 2d object
detection is pretty much a solved problem.
And we already have very good algorithms
like YOLO that do our tasks. However,
there is some research that is still required on
3d object detection, which was also the motivation
behind why Lyft conducted this competition as
well. Alright, so this is it for this video.
For this particular project, we are going to
use several videos that were recorded by a
camera that was placed in front of an autonomous
car. So let's have a look at one of the videos.
In this video, we can see that
there are two cars that are moving.
And this is another video of
the same highway scenario.
Saw data set has six videos that contain
this highway scenario. For object tracking,
we need to keep track of both of these cars that
are moving in front of us. If we assign an ID to
both of these cars, if we say this is the black
car, and this is the white car, then in each frame
of the video, we need to keep detecting where
is the black car and where is the white car.
This has to be done for the complete
duration of the video. In Object Tracking,
we are not only required to detect where
the car is present in this particular frame.
But we also need to remember that this is the
car that has been assigned the ID black car.
And this is the car that has been assigned the
ID white car, the link to this dataset would
be present in the description box below. Okay,
so now we have defined object detection problem
and had a look at the dataset. Now let us
understand how this deep sort algorithm works. As
you may have seen before, in object tracking, not
only do we need to detect the objects, but also
track where they are going. So we consider this
collection of images, or we can see a video,
we can see that we have two objects that are
moving in this video, it is this round object
that is going in the horizontal direction and one
object that is going in the vertical direction.
In Object Tracking, we are not only detecting
where are the objects present in this image,
but we are also tracking where the
objects I did one and two are going.
So this is the whole problem of object tracking.
In our case, it would be traffic tracking,
we need to keep a track of the different cars
that are moving around our autonomous vehicle.
So the algorithm that we're going to use to solve
this object tracking problem is called the deep
sort algorithm. Before discussing the deep sort
algorithm, we would first start our discussion
with the simple sort algorithm. So R stands for
Simple online real time tracking. And the simple
sort algorithm uses bounding box prediction,
Kalman filters and IOU matching techniques.
First let us start with bounding box predictions.
The first step in this algorithm is to generate
bounding boxes or detect where are the
objects present in the image. Now, this
can be accomplished using any CNN architecture it
can be YOLO it can be our CNN or it can even be a
simple computer vision handcrafted model. For our
project we have used the Yolo v3 algorithm briefly
what you know v3 algorithm does given an input
image it is going to detect all the objects that
are present in that image, draw a bounding box
around them, and also tell us what that object is.
After we generated the bounding box predictions
we get to the next step, which is the Kalman
filter. Now Kalman filter is a very broad topic,
which would take an entire video to explain, but
still we would be left with a lot of ground
to cover. So to briefly discuss Kalman filter,
we can say in very simple terms that Kalman
filter is a linear approximation. So what is
the role of kalman filter over here? Kalman
filter needs to predict what is going to be
the future location of a given detected
object. Using these future predictions
we can determine whether the object that we
were tracking isn't the same object or not.
Along with that, using prediction, we can
also deal with the problem of occlusion.
So what is occlusion? In this example above,
we can see between these these two frames,
the two balls are going to overlap each other. And
whichever object is in front is going to occlude
the object that is present behind it. In order
to deal with this problem in object tracking,
predictions are useful. So how does Kalman filter
works? Kalman filter assumes a linear velocity
model and generates the predictions according to
it. Once we get the real data where the object is,
we input that again to the Kalman filter. The
Kalman filter improves its predictions based on
the real data that it got, and again generates a
new set of predictions. In this way Kalman filter
works in an iterative manner and keeps improving
its predictions. As an output, the Kalman filter
does not output a single number, actually, it
outputs a probability distribution of where the
object can be in a given set of locations. If we
take the maximum value of that probability, we can
in some way approximate where the object is going
to be. This is the work of the Kalman filter,
it generates future predictions for the objects.
The next step we have is called IO U matching.
Io U stands for intersection over Union. In brief
terms, we can say IOU gives us a quantitative
score to determine how much two bounding boxes
are similar to each other based on their location
in the image as well as the size, but is this
IOU matching in the context of sort algorithm,
let us consider this case, we have n different
cards that we are detecting in a particular
frame. And we have n IDs that we need to assign
to these particular cards, like in this case,
IDs are useful to determine which object we are
tracking. So we need to assign these n detections
to these n IDs. For each of the n IDs, we have
IOU score corresponding to each detection in a
descriptive way, we have the detected objects
in the row, and we have the IDs in the columns.
So for each of the ID and the GS detection, we
have an IOU score. Now we want to assign the IOU
scores to these n detections in such a way that
the total IOU score is maximized. solving this
problem using brute force approach takes order
complexity n factorial, which is very large.
In order to solve this, the sort algorithm uses
the Hungarian algorithm, the Hungarian algorithm
solves this linear assignment problem in order
complexity n cubed, which is a great improvement
over the n factorial algorithm. Once we have
assigned these n predictions to N IDs, we have
in a sense solved the tracking problem for the AI
X frame, then we can run this algorithm again in
a loop and again, keep track of the objects that
are in the next frame of the video. So this is how
the simple salt algorithm works. Not deep salt
is an extension of the simple sort algorithm.
Now that deep in the deep salt comes from this
step called the deep appearance descriptor step.
Along with that, we also have a cascade matching
step that is added to the simple sort algorithm.
So deep appearance descriptor is a convolutional
neural network, which is trained to detect a
similar object in different images. What this
means this, this network can tell given a number
of images of the same person in different views,
whether it is the same person or not. So as an
input, the deep descriptor receives a cropped
image of the object detected. And as an output,
we try to receive a vector that encodes the
information that is present in that crowd image,
these encoded vectors would allow us to compare
different objects. So now we have two models
that are describing us about similar
objects in different frames of a video,
we combined the score given by these two models in
a linear fashion. The score by the deep descriptor
is given using the cosine distance metric, and
the score by the Kalman filter is given by the
melanomas distance before discussing how these
metrics are computed. Let us first discuss the
notion of a distance metric. A distance metric
is a score that we assign to two different
entities A and B to tell how similar they are.
For instance, if we consider it to deep plane
on that plane, we have two points A and B.
We compute the distance from the origin.
If the two entities A and B are close to each
other then distance from the origin is also going
to be similar in value. If the two entities
A and B are very dissimilar to each other,
then these two entities are going to have a
Euclidean distance that is very dissimilar,
we can say one is going to have a negative value,
the other one is going to have a positive value
if they are lying on the two sides of the Y axis.
In these two cases, we need to use another notion
of distance metric. For the deep descriptors, we
use the cosine distance metric, how do we compute
this? If we are given two entities A and B. And
from the origin, we draw a vector joining these
and then we calculate the angle between these two
vectors, the cosine value of this angle is going
to give us the cosine distance metric. Let us
consider an example. If we have two vectors that
are overlapping each other, the angle between them
is going to be zero, and the cosine value of zero
is going to be one. This means that these
two vectors are very similar to each other.
However, if two vectors are perpendicular to each
other, the cosine value of 90 is going to be zero.
This would mean that these two vectors are very
dissimilar to each other. In this way, we would be
able to determine whether the two objects that we
detected how much similar they are to each other.
For the Kalman filter case, we are not using the
cosine similarity. A reason for this is the Kalman
filter is going to output not a single point, but
a probability distribution. In order to compare
the similarity between a point and a probability
distribution, we use melanomas distance.
If we consider that this is the distribution that
is output by the Kalman filter, this implies that
the probability of the object being over here
is very high compared to the values outwards.
And this is the point that we want to
compare with this probability distribution.
In very simple terms, what melanomas distance
does, for a 2d version, we compute the two
directions in which the data spread is the
highest. For this case, we can see the data
spread is the highest in this direction and a
perpendicular this direction. Then we normalize
and transform the coordinate axes in such a way
that these two axes become the coordinate axes.
In that transformed space, we calculate
the distance of this point from the origin,
a value of that distance is the melanomas
distance. Using this metric, we decide how much
a given prediction by the Kalman filter matches an
object that we just detected. Combining these two,
we get an overall scalar score value that
we can use to assign detections to their ids
using the N Galeon algorithm. However, in
the implementation, there is a slight catch,
the authors of the deep sort algorithm noticed
that the predictions by the Kalman filter are not
very useful, and the score for these predictions
can be neglected. However, you will see that
in our project, this doesn't work very well. The
next step that we have is cascade matching. Gaskin
matching is an extension to the IOU matching
algorithm for the assignment problem, the cascade
matching takes into account the temporal dimension
as well, in order to reduce the time complexity
for the Hungarian algorithm cascade matching tries
and match the latest detections with the latest
IDs and the later or old detections with the
old IDs. All of this process combined gives us
the deep salt algorithm. And we can again run this
algorithm in a loop to track objects in a complete
video. Alright, so this is all for the explanation
part of the deep sort algorithm. Now let's have
a brief look at the code and the results and see
how it worked for our project. So let's do this.
The link to this code or notebook will be
provided in the description box below as well.
So, these are the different sub parts
of the complete deep sort algorithm.
The first part is the Yolo v3 network that is used
to generate the bounding boxes. The second step
is the detections part where we encode the
given cropped image. The third part is the
Kalman filter, where we use the Kalman
filter to generate the predictions.
The next part is the IOU matching in this
part, we solve the linear assignment problem
and the Cascade matching that we discussed
before. Next up is the nearest neighbor matching.
This contains the code for the Euclidean
distance as well as the cosine distance.
The next part is tracking. This combines all the
different modes To do that we developed before
to create a final object that does the complete
tracking. Finally, we have the object tracking
where we run the complete algorithm. This file
over here contains the pre trained network for
deep appears descriptive II have this function
object tracking that takes in the video path
input, and also takes the output path there
to save the output video. Now let's have a
look at the results of how the final video
looks like. So this is the first video,
as we can see this one and two, these are the IDs
that are assigned to these two cars respectively.
This is the second video.
As we can see, the car over
here was assigned the ID nine.
And even in some frames, the yellow
algorithm was not able to detect that car.
Even after those Miss detections, the algorithm
was able to determine that this was the car
labeled ID nine l now we had a look at the
videos where the algorithm was performing
really well. Now let's have a look at the video
where the algorithm didn't perform that well.
In this video, we can see that we have
this car labeled 12. And we have this new
car that is labeled 35. Now you will see what
is the problem that this algorithm is facing.
Due to the occlusion that
was given by this black car.
This car is now the identified as the ID 36
and not the ID 12 That it was assigned before.
So this is one problem that deep sort algorithm
faced due to a longer occlusion period,
the algorithm was not able to detect the
correct ID for the car. Even after checking
different hyper parameter values, I was not
able to get rid of this ID assignment problem.
This I believe would be due to assigning an
negligible amount of weight to the Kalman
filter predictions. Possibly if we increase the
weight for the Kalman filter predictions, this
problem would be solved. But that is an extension
to the project that we developed in this video,
and will be looked as a future work to this
project. Alright, so this is it for this video.
Okay, so these are the images that are part of
the TT 3d object detection data set as we can see.
And these are the LIDAR data
provided in the data set as well.
For instance, we can see a
wall in this image over here,
the same wall, it has a correspondence in the
LIDAR scan as well as we can see over here.
These curvy lines are the projections of
the LIDAR that fell on the road itself. All
also if we consider another example, we can
see this car in front of the image. This same
car can be seen over here, which is blocking
the LIDAR signals. Another cool visualization
that we have is the LIDAR data presented in
the form of a camera as we can see over here
as we saw in the image earlier,
we had a car in front of us,
we can see that car similarly in these LIDAR scans
as well. Another example is this car over here.
This car, this car as well as
the traffic signal can be seen
in this LIDAR scan as well. And this
is another visualization of the LIDAR
data as well as the bounding box that are
given in that 3d object detection data set.
Alright, so these are all the visualizations. Now
let us understand what is the theory behind how we
generate these visualizations. Okay, now in order
to understand how are we generating these data
visualizations, first step, we need to understand
the concept of homogeneous transformations.
In a general self driving car setting. We
usually have two main sensors which are Lidar
and the camera. Typically, these Lidar and
camera sensors are not going to be placed
at the same location. They are going to have
different locations turns on a car. For instance,
in this case, the Lidar is on top of the car,
and the camera is on the front head of the car.
Camera, as we all know, is a visual sensor,
we use it to capture a 2d scene of a given
3d environment. Lidar, on the other hand
is a perception sensor. It is used to map
a 3d environment using a rotating laser. LIDAR
generates what are called the point clouds. Point
Clouds provide a very good representation of a
given 3d environment. Now, this is a very general
use case that we want to see the data that was
captured by a lidar in the frame of a camera. What
I mean by that, if through our eyes, we are seeing
how the environment is looking like from here,
we also need to see how the same environment at
the same time is going to look like when we see it
from over here at the camera location. In order to
convert between these given reference points, we
use what are called homogeneous transformations.
If we consider that we are given two coordinate
axes, the blue one over here, and the red one over
here, and we have this object, this black dot that
we want to see through both of these coordinate
axes. Mathematically, this problem translates to,
if we are given the vector from the origin of
this coordinate axis to this point over here,
which we call x, we need to find x dash, which
is a vector starting from the origin of this
coordinate axis to the same point given this
coordinate axis is called transformation. Now,
any general transformation can be divided into two
subproblems, which are translation and rotation.
Translation is simply moving the origin of this
coordinate axis to some other location in space.
If we have a coordinate axis like this,
and we simply move this to a new location,
then we have what is called a translation.
In rotation, however, we would like to change
the direction in which these axes are pointing.
However, the origin is going to remain at the same
place. In order to understand rotation better, we
can divide the rotation operation into three sub
operations, which are rotation about the x axis,
rotation about the y axis and rotation about
the z axis. A combination of all these three
rotations gives us the actual rotation
that is going to finally take place.
Without going into much depth, let us see how the
mathematical representations of these look like.
In order to get the translated vector, we simply
need to add another vector to our original vector.
In this case, we are adding this ABC vector
to our original x to get x t, which is the
translated vector, the rotation operation can
be understood as a matrix multiplication. If
we consider this three cross three matrix, and we
multiply this matrix with our original vector x,
we get a rotated vector XR, however, we need to
keep this in mind, the values of this translation
vector can be taken anything, but the parameters
of this matrix are bounded between a range
combining these two sub operations of translation
and rotation, we get what is called a homogeneous
transformation. What homogeneous transformation
does, it simply reduces translation and rotation
into a single matrix multiplication, as we can
see over here. So how we derive this matrix
multiplier, first up, we take the rotation matrix
and place it in the upper left corner over here,
we take this translation vector, we place
it in the upper right corner over here,
and these remaining part, this last row is
filled with three zeros and a one. This will
look something like this, this three cross
three matrix is the rotation matrix. And
this three dimensional vector is the translation
vector, rest zeros and ones are placed over here.
Now following the rules of matrix multiplication,
given this is a full Cross for matrix, it can only
be multiplied with a vector of dimensionality for
in order to make this three dimensional vector,
a four dimensional vector, what we
do is place a one over here. Hence,
our complete operation looks like this. We'll
take this matrix, we multiply this matrix with
this extended vector. And what we get as an
output is this extended vector over here,
because of the structure of this matrix over here,
this one over here is a guaranteed number. Using
this operation, we Finally get a vector x dash
representing the point x in a new frame of access.
Now, in order to convert this given 3d data
into a 2d representative screen, just like
we have in a camera, we use the operations that
we will discuss over here. Now mathematically,
how does a camera work? If we consider this
red coordinate axis as the camera axis,
we have this point in the 3d scene that
we can see through this camera axis.
Now we define a new point which is called the
camera Center, which is taken to be the origin
of this coordinate axis over here. Now all the
points that are situated at a distance of one
unit from this camera center in the direction
of z axis, is what we call the image plane.
Now this image plane is a plane to the surface,
which has defined its x&y coordinates in this
direction, the x direction is taken upward and y
direction is taken along this direction. We can
also understand this image plane as sitting at
the camera center and watching a cinema screen
that is one unit away from us. Now
this complete problem boils down to
if we are given this 3d point, we want
to project this 3d point to this image.
That is, how would this 3d Point look like if
we were to see it in a 2d projected image plane.
And this is exactly what a camera does converts a
3d scene into a 2d image. We accomplish this using
the similar homogeneous transformations. If we
are given a transformation matrix M, we can simply
multiply that with a 3d object vector x dash and
get a new vector, which is x double dash. Also,
in order to get how these points would look like
in this image plane, we need to divide the X and
Y coordinates of this newly x double dash vector
with its Z coordinate, which we can see over here.
Solving both of these operations, we would get the
transformation of a 3d point on a 2d image plane.
In our case, how that works out is we are given
the point cloud that is generated by the LIDAR
using these operations. We can see how that
LiDAR point cloud is going to look like
when we put it on an image that is generated by a
camera. Now this complete concept of homogeneous
Transformations is very fundamental to
robotics as well as computer vision.
It is used in self driving cars, mobile robots,
and even robot manipulators in computer vision.
Apart from this application, it is also used in
3d scene reconstruction. Now the parameters used
for the operations that we did on this side
of the board are called extrinsic parameters.
And the parameters that we used for this side
of the board are called intrinsic parameters.
Extrinsic parameters are external to the camera
and depend on how the camera is placed. Intrinsic
parameters depend on the internals of a camera,
for instance, the focal length of the camera lens,
there are a number of different ways we can use to
determine what are the extrinsic and the intrinsic
parameters of a given camera. One very popular
way to determine these is the checkerboard method.
In this method, we take a printed
photo of a chest or a checkerboard.
And we click its images in different positions and
angles. We apply a number of different operations
to those images to determine the extrinsic and
intrinsic parameters of the camera. This is all
the theory that we needed to discuss for the data
visualization. Now let's have a brief look at the
code of how this data visualization is working.
So let's get to it. All the code that we are
using to generate these 3d visualizations will
be present in the description box below as well.
Alright, so now first, let us discuss how we
generate this LIDAR data in the form of a camera.
In order to convert we have this points array
over here. This array contains all the points
of the point cloud that were captured by the
LIDAR. We pass this points array to a function
called Velo to Cam. Along with that, we also
pass the extrinsic camera metrics. Well to Cam
over here stands for velodyne to camera velodyne
is the LIDAR sensor that was used over here.
All in all what this Vallo two cam
function does, it takes this cloud
array and it takes this v two C matrix, and it
simply does a matrix multiplication on them.
Once we get the points in the camera reference,
we then calculate a matrix multiplication of those
points with the intrinsic camera matrix. And we
do the division operation over here. And finally,
we fill in different colors using this expression
over here. And calling this function on
different set of point clouds gives us this the
following visualization that we see over here.
generating this view of the LIDAR
also called the bird's eye view,
is relatively simple. We simply
take the points of the point cloud
and scale them in such a way that they
occupy the complete frame of a given image.
And then finally, fill the different colors
that are present in over here. And this is
how we get the bird's eye view of the LIDAR data.
Getting this image visualization is pretty simple.
And this data is already provided. And we do
not need to do any processing over here as such.
Getting the boxes to print over here is also
simple, just like how we did for the LiDAR,
we use the extrinsic and intrinsic
camera parameters to accomplish the same
and this is just a Combined
view of the Lidar and the boxes.
Alright, so this is all for this video.
Alright, so the problem of multi task learning is
such that we want to derive a single network that
can be used for various different computer vision
tasks. The data set that we are going to use for
this particular project is the cityscapes dataset,
the link for this data scraped would be present in
the description box below. The cityscape data set
consists of different Street View images, that is
images taken from a car that is being driven on
the road. This data set is particularly used for
depth estimation and semantic segmentation. Let's
have a look at the images present in the dataset
and what these two tasks are. So these are the
different images that are present in the data set.
Okay, now, let us discuss what is the depth
estimation task. As the name implies in this task,
we want to calculate the depth of any
object that is present in the image.
Let us have a look at some of the example
images to make this point more clear.
In this image, we have this struct that is front
of our car. And through the color gradient we
can see that the depth is almost constant in
front of this. We can also observe other such
features from this gradient color. The areas
close to the car are slightly darker in color
and as we move away from the car, the colors
get slightly lighter. As we can see over here.
A similar look we can have over here,
there is a car present near our car,
and we can see a very dark color for
that car. And as the objects go away,
the color gets lighter and lighter. Let's
have a look at some more example images.
So the overall work in this task is to calculate
depth maps, and the depth maps without the
underlying image looks something like this.
For the image segmentation tasks, we need to
segment different objects that are present in
the image. Let's have a look at some example
images. In this example all the cars and
vehicles are segmented in a yellow color. And the
trees and background are segmented in red color.
Something similar can be observed in this image as
well. Let's have a look at another example images
So, the overall work in this task is to calculate
segmentation labels which we can
see in the example images over here.
Alright, so, this is the visualization
of the data that we are going to use.
Now, let us have a look at the technique
that we are going to use to solve the
multitask learning problem. Alright, so the
problem of multitask learning is as follows.
We want to derive a network that can
be used to solve different tasks,
these different tasks can be object detection,
object classification, and Object segmentation.
The constraint in this problem is that we cannot
have different networks for these different tasks,
we have to use a single network that is run once
and trained once to solve all the different tasks.
The advantage it has over distributed networks is
that we don't have to train each and every network
individually for the different tasks resulting
in saving some time. So the technique that we're
going to discuss for this multitask learning
is m 10. M 10 stands for multi task attention
network. And this is the architecture that M tan
follows. Given an input image, the first step we
do is calculate the shared features of that given
input image. Then we have task specific modules
that use those shared features to solve their
given task. For n number of tasks, we are going to
have n specific attention modules. These attention
modules take some data from the shared features
and augment it in such a way that is useful
for their particular task. The word attention
over here refers to the attention that
each module gives do its particular task.
For the intent technique, we can use any
convolutional network to calculate the shared
features for our particular project, we are going
to use set net to calculate the shared features.
Now signal is a network that is used to solve the
image segmentation task in the image segmentation
task, we would be given an input image and the
task is to segment the different objects that are
present in that image. For this image segmentation
task, the networks that are used have a general
structure and general structure is such that we
are given an input image the first step we do
is downsample the image and derive the features
from that image once we downsample the image and
reach the bottleneck, we have sample the image
to the same dimension as the given input image.
And with the help of the features
derived in the downsampling task
output a segmentation mask. The downsampling
part of the network is also called the encoder
and the upsampling part of the network is also
called the decoder. The only difference between
Cygnet and fully convolutional neural networks
is the operation that we use for upsampling.
So the Signet architecture has different
convolution blocks. As you can see over here,
these convolution blocks comprise of convolution
layers followed by some pooling layers. Now, the
M 10 architecture is in such a way that for each
of these convolution blocks, we have attention
some modules, these sub modules are for the blue
tasks and these sub modules are for the red task.
The arrows over here show the data flow that is
happening between the overall network. Now there
are some differences in the upsampling attention
modules and the downsampling attention modules.
Let us discuss them in slight detail. For
the upsample attention module, we get the
input from the previous attention module which
we can see over here. And we take another input
that is derived from the first layer of the
convolutional block as we can see over here,
these two matrices are merged the convolution
operation on them is computed twice
and then we calculate the element wise
multiplication of the output generated
over here and the input of one of the filters of
these convolution blocks as we can see over here,
then this element wise multiplication
is once again sent through a convolution
block and the output is returned to the next
attention module. For the downsampling module,
we we take the input from the previous
attention module, which we can see over here
This input is sent through a convolution
block which is then merged with the input
of the first layer of the convolution
block which is present over here.
This merge filter is passed
twice through convolution blocks,
then an element wise multiplication
is calculated for this output,
and the input that is taken from one of the layers
of convolution block as we can see over here.
And this final output is sent
to the next attention module,
the attention module is only different for the
up sampling and down sampling phase of the shared
feature network. For the different tasks, the
attention module architecture is exactly the same.
And this is the complete network architecture of
the M 10 network. One additional technique that
M 10 proposes is what is called dynamic weighted
averaging. For any multi task learning network,
we calculate the loss by a weighted average of
the loss calculated for the different tasks as
you can see over here, the adjustment
of the weights of these losses is very
important for the network to actually
converge and learn the different tasks.
Dynamic weight averaging is a technique
that is used to determine these weights
based on the rate of change of the gradient loss.
Now, what is the rate of change of gradient loss,
if we consider two training batches of images
input to the network at time t and time t
plus one the difference between the loss that is
back propagated at time t plus one and time t is
what is called the rate of change or gradient
loss, we calculate these weight values by taking
a softmax kind of average using the rate of
change of loss. And this technique gives us
the optimal value of the weights that we
should have for these individual losses.
So, these are the two main contributions of
the multitask attention network technique.
So, this is all the theory that we
need to cover for the M 10 technique.
Now, let us have a brief look at the code and the
results generated using this technique. Okay, so,
the code or notebook for this m 10 would be
present in the description box below as well.
So, the first thing that we have done over here
is implement the data set loader class which we
can see over here. Now, this data set loader
class is specific to the cityscapes data set,
the architecture that we discussed can be
applied to a number of different data sets.
And for those data sets, we would have
to implement those specific classes.
Then, we have defined the utility functions
model fit which is used to train the model.
We also have the different metrics, the confusion
matrix and the depth error. And then we have
this function called multi task trainer, which
handles the complete training of the network.
We have also defined the network in this
Cygnet class. Finally, we load the data set
and train it on the dataset. One thing to note
is that the authors of this technique trained
the network on 200 epochs with a learning rate of
10 raise to power minus four. However, due to the
constraints imposed by candle on the training time
doesn't allow us to experiment with these values.
Hence, for this particular experiment, the
epochs are taken to be 100 and the learning
rate is taken to be 10 raised to one minus three.
The results of the training are decent and good.
However, it would have been better if we use the
parameters that were provided by the authors.
Let us have a look at some of the
results. The left one is the original
segmentation map and the right one
is the predicted segmentation map.
As we can see, there are slight issues that this
network faces while segmenting by cycles. But
the overall results don't look good. These are
the segmentation results overlaid on the image.
Now let's have a look at the depth maps the left
one is the original depth map and the
right one is the predicted Depth Map.
For the depth map we can also say there
are slight errors here and there but the
results overall do seem good. Now, these
are the depth maps overlaid on the image
All right, so this is it for this video.
Alright, so the data set that we're going to use
for this video is the kit a 3d object detection
data set, we will quickly go over this data
set in this video as well. This data set has
images that are taken from the front camera of
a self driving car as we can see them over here.
We are also provided with a LIDAR data
that was captured by LIDAR present on
the self driving car as we can see them over here.
And these are the LIDAR data
projected in the view of a camera.
So this is the dataset that we are going to work
with. Now the cool thing about SFA 3d technique
is that this network only uses the LIDAR data
to do the 3d object detection task. Hence,
the images that present in this data set are
not used at all. Another thing to note as well.
This data that we're visualizing over here
is a processed form of the city 3d object
detection dataset. However, for generating
the final output of that technique,
we are going to use the raw form of the KT data
set that is provided in the form of a video feed,
the real time video feed and the LIDAR data
feed would be used for the final prediction
tasks. Alright, so this is all for the data
set. Now let us discuss the technical details
of this asset with 3d technique. Okay, so as we
discussed, we are going to use SFA 3d for the
3d object detection task SFA. 3d stands for
super fast and accurate 3d object detection.
So SFA 3d as a complete technique does 3d
object detection using only the LIDAR data?
As an input we provide SFA 3d as a bird's eye
view input image to the network. The network
predicts the different objects that are present
in that image and also classifies them as well.
The data collected using a lidar is a 3d data.
When we view that 3d data from a top view
that top view is also called the bird's eye view
of that given scene. Once you provide the network
with the bird's eye view image of the LIDAR seen
as an output, we get seven outputs. These seven
outputs are heat maps of the different
classes that are present in the image,
the distance of the center of other objects
from our ego car or the self driving car,
the angles in which the other objects are facing
the dimensions of the objects that we have
detected, the length width and the height
and the z coordinate of the center of that object
as we can see over here. So now we have discussed
the input as well as the list of outputs that
sma 3d provides us now SFA 3d mainly consists of
three components, which are key point FPN,
the different losses that we're going to use
for this network and the learning rate scheduling
technique that we employ for the training.
Let us discuss these techniques one by one.
The first component that we're going to discuss
is the key point SPN before discussing key
point FPN let us first discuss what is FPN SBN
stands for feature pyramid network feature pyramid
network is a feature feature extraction technique
that given a single input image outputs
different feature maps that vary in size.
It's something as you can see over here, given
a single input image, the outputs are different
feature maps of different sizes. So what is
feature extraction and feature maps. All the
important data that is contained inside an image
is what are called features. They can be points,
edges, designs and patterns or even human faces.
In a convolutional neural network, we have what
are called convolution blocks. These convolution
blocks consist of different convolution layers
and pooling layers. We provide an input image to
these convolution blocks, and we get an output
image or we can say a matrix. This output image
or metrics are what are called feature maps.
The process of extracting features out of a given
image is what is called Feature Extraction. Now,
feature pyramid networks is not a network by name,
it's actually a general technique that we can
employ on a number of different neural networks.
For instance, we can apply this feature pyramid
network technique to generate feature maps on a
ResNet architecture as well. By post processing
these output feature maps, we can do a number of
different tasks like object detection, the feature
pyramid network technique works in this way. Given
this input image, we pass it through a number of
different convolution blocks, and ensure that
these images get smaller in size. As we can see,
over here, the input image is getting smaller
in size as we approach the tip of the pyramid.
Then we employ successive iterations of
convolutional blocks, ensuring that they up sample
the given image as we can see over here, the image
gets larger in size. As we approach the base of
the pyramid network, along with the convolutions
that we apply in this part of the network. We also
provide information to this part of the
network from the previous part of the network,
as we can see through the
skip connections over here,
and we generate the output feature maps from
this part of the network as we can see over here.
Now, feature pyramid networks are a great
technique to employ if we want to create
networks that are scale invariant. So what is
scale invariant network? Let us assume that we
want to predict a ball that is present on an
image using a simple convolutional network.
If the ball that is present in that image
of large size or that ball is of small size,
the neural network should be able to detect
the ball that is present in that image. This
property of detecting irrespective of the size of
that object is what is called scale invariance.
for tasks like object detection, we need to
predict a bounding box that tells us where that
object is present in that image. For tasks like
these scaling variants is an important property
that neural networks are supposed to have.
However, for detecting points in a given image,
scaling variants does not play a major role. If
we want to detect a single point in a given image,
that point is going to remain at the same
location, irrespective of the scaling that
we apply on that image. Hence, directly applying
feature pyramid networks to detect points in an
image is not an efficient technique. Key Point
feature pyramid networks are an extension to
the given SPM networks that help us detect points
in a given image. The overall architecture of key
point FPN remains the same, the outputs of the SPN
can be visualized, as we can see over here. These
Gaussian shaped outputs that we see over here
indicate that the network is really confident
that a point is present at a given location in
the image. But as we move away from that point,
the confidence level of the network goes
down, as we can see from the shape over here.
So once we have these feature output
maps, we convert these feature maps to
a similar size. In this particular case,
we have taken the reference size to be the
largest feature map that is present with us.
We upsample the smaller feature maps to match
the size of the largest feature map that we
have, as we can see in this column over here.
Then we calculate a weighted average of This
feature maps and get a final single output as
we can see over here, the weights of the weighted
average are dependent on the confidence value that
the network has in this different feature maps.
From this feature map, we can take the point that
has the highest confidence value and output
that as the point that we wanted to detect
this complete post processing that we have done
after the simple SPM network is what constitutes
the key point FPN network. Alright, so this is
the complete network architecture of the SFA 3d
techniques. Now let us discuss the different
loss functions that are employed to train
this network. First off, we are going to discuss
the outputs that are generated by this network.
The first output is a heat map of the different
classes. Heat Map is a data visualization
technique that tells us the magnitude of a given
phenomena occurring on a given input. Roughly,
we can visualize a heat map using a mountain
terrain. Usually in a mountainous range,
we have a mountain that has the highest peak,
and has accompanying hills or mountains that
are off smaller peaks, then this highest peak
Mountain. As we move away from this highest peak,
the height of the ground also starts decreasing
in all the directions something like this.
As we move away from that highest peak, we
approach another neighboring mountain or a hill.
After the height decreases, the height
again starts increasing until we reach
the top or the peak of the neighboring mountain.
And once again, as we move away from that peak,
the height again starts decreasing. If we view
such a mountainous region from the top view,
and visualize the height of the ground in
that image, we get what is called a heat map.
If we denote a larger height by a dark red
color, and a lower height by a white color,
we are going to observe that the
highest peak has a solid red color.
As we move away from that peak, that solid red
color is going to decay into a white color. Again,
as we approach another peak, that white color is
going to converge into a solid red color. Again,
a heat map can also be visualized in terms
of confidence of a network that it has on
its predictions. In our particular case, if we
want to detect three objects, let's say a car,
a truck and a pedestrian, we are going to
generate three different heat maps. In this case,
the red color denotes that there is a car that is
present in that image at this particular location,
and the network is confident about this location.
Similarly, a pedestrian is present in this
location, and the network is confident about
its prediction in this particular location.
As we move away from both these locations,
the confidence of the network goes down.
Using this heat map, we detect the class of
the object whether it is a car or a pedestrian.
In order to encourage the network to learn the
right classes, we use what is called a focal loss.
The mathematical expression of the
focal loss is something like this.
Focal loss is usually used when there
exists a class imbalance in the data.
class imbalance usually occurs when there is
a less amount of data for a particular class
and a very high amount of data
for another particular class.
Here P T is the confidence value of the network.
This scaling factor over here allows the network
to focus its learning more on the predictions that
it is less confident about and focus less on the
predictions that it is more confident about. Next
output we have are the distance from the ego car
and the direction in which the other
objects are facing. In order to learn this,
we use what is called an L one loss. The
mathematical expression is something like this.
elven loss simply takes the difference of the
prediction and the actual value and computes the
absolute value of that difference. The next output
that we have are the dimensions of the object we
are trying to detect and its Z coordinate
the distance or the height from the ground.
In order to learn these four parameters, we use
what is called a balanced Elvan loss. Now given
a training data, we can divide the points in that
data roughly into two categories, outliers and In
liars white training a network that data points
that generate a loss value that is less than some
threshold, let us say one are called in liars. And
the data points that have a loss that is greater
than that threshold are called outliers. Due to a
larger value of loss, the outliers tend to attract
the neural network weights towards itself. Due to
a smaller loss value, the inliers are not able to
attract the neural network weights towards itself
that sufficiently well. In order to efficiently
deal with such an imbalance of loss values,
we use what is called a balanced elven loss.
The balanced elven loss balances the loss values
that are generated by both of these inliers and
outliers to get a network that performs well
on both these types of data. Alright, so,
these are all the losses that are used in this
network. The next component that we are going
to discuss is the learning rate scheduling. While
training a neural network the learning rate is an
important hyper parameter that we need to take
care of a particular technique that we apply to
better train a network is called learning rate
scheduling. During the training process, we tend
to decrease or increase the learning rate values
in order to fine tune our optimization process.
The learning rate decay technique that we
use in this network is the cosine annealing,
the graph of the learning rate in cosine annealing
looks something like this towards the start
the learning rate decreases slowly towards
the middle the learning rate starts decreasing
in a linear fashion and towards the end, the
learning rate decrease again starts to slow down.
The combination of all these three components
is what constitutes the SFA 3d technique,
alright. So, these are all the technical details
there are to discuss for the SFA 3d technique.
Now, let us see this algorithm in action.
Okay, so let us have a brief look at the code.
The link to this code and the notebook will be
provided in the description box below as well.
The first step that we have
is the configuration step.
Here we set up the different parameters
and variables that we are going to use
for our network. Next up, we have the different
data processing functions that we use. One such
data processing technique is to convert the LIDAR
data into a bird's eye view of the given data.
Next up, we have different utility functions like
logging that we use to log the training process
learning rate scheduling that we
use while training the network
and different visualization utility functions that
we use to visualize and generate the final output.
Next up in this section, we define
the different loss functions that
we are using to train the network.
Finally, we define the FPN ResNet
network over here in this section and in this
section, we finally train the neural network.
One particular problem that 3d object detection
network face is training. The training of these
networks is really time consuming and require
very expensive and good quality hardware.
Since we have a time limit and some constraints
on hardware on Kaggle I was not able to train
the network by myself. Hence I have used the pre
trained weights that are provided along with this
network architecture. So now let us have a look
at the final output. So this is the final output
that we have on the raw data set for the purpose
of visualization I have slowed down this video.
Okay, so some key observations that we can note
over here, red boxes describe the cars that are
in the same. Blue bounding boxes are for cyclists
that are present in the scene and yellow bounding
boxes. for pedestrians on the given scene, one
interesting observation is that the network is
not able to detect that tram that is present in
this image, since it was not trained on that data.
Also, these blue lines describe the
orientation of the various surrounding cars.
Alright, so, this is all that is
to discuss of the SFA 3d technique.
So, let us start with the problem definition.
In this problem given a set of images taken
from the different cameras present
on a self driving car, or a robot,
we are required to process these images and
output a bird's eye view of the given environment.
Bird's Eye View or top view are
viewing the 3d scenes from the top
as an input, we can either have a single image or
we can have multiple different images taken from
the different cameras. In this case, we can see
this is our self driving car. And in this case,
for our particular problem, we have four cameras
in the front, left, right and the back. Given
these four images, we are required to process them
and output the bird's eye view of the environment
around the car. As you can see over here, the red
rectangle is the ego car or our self driving car
and the other blue rectangles are the other cars.
Now why do we require to calculate this bird's eye
view of the environment? There are mainly
two reasons we would like to calculate the
bird's eye view. The first application is object
detection. Calculating a bird's eye view of the
given environment provides us with a different
way of doing object detection compared to other
different computer vision methods. The second or
the more important application is path planning.
This bird's eye view provides us with a concise
representation of the surrounding environment, the
different cars and objects that are present in the
scene and the road that we are required to go on.
Using this concise representation we can easily
implement path planning algorithms on our self
driving car. So, this is the complete introduction
to the problem statement. Now, let us have a look
at the data set that we are going to work with in
this project. Alright, so the link to this data
and this data visualization notebook would
be provided in the description box below.
Just like in the problem description, we
are given four images, the front, the rear,
left and right. Along with that, we are given
certain bird's eye view images. Now the images
that we have been given are not exactly real
time images, but semantic segmented images.
We already have the different classes in these
images, semantically segmented and we have to
derive a bird's eye view image for the same. The
cool thing about this dataset is that the data set
is derived from a simulation, the self driving
car drives around the simulation environment.
And we captured the different images from
the four different cameras that are present
on the self driving car. A drone
flies just above a self driving car
in order to capture the ground truth bird's eye
view images. As we can see, we have these four
images taken from the self driving car cameras,
the front image, the rear image, the left image
and the right image. And this is the ground truth
bird's eye view image of the 3d environment.
This next image the bird's eye view occlusion
image contains occlusion as a separate class.
This means that the scene that is hidden
or occluded by different objects in the
environment are represented using a separate
class. As we can see in this gray color over here
this car present behind our self driving car
is blocking the view of the camera in this gray
space. Additionally, some buildings are also
occluding the space as we can see over here,
and due to this occlusion, we are not able to
see this car that is present behind the building
and is not visible through our camera. This
homography image is similar to the bird's eye
view image that we have over here, but contains a
lot of noise. So what is the homography operation?
In simple terms using a homography operation,
we can convert from one image plane to
another image plane. In this particular case,
we are converting from these four images,
the front rear left and right and using
these to generate a bird's eye view image.
This Bird's Eye View conversion operation is also
called inverse perspective mapping. More on this
homography and inverse perspective mapping will
be discussed in the later part of the video and we
will understand why we do not use this technique
directly to derive the bird's eye view image.
Now, let us have a look at few
instances of this data set.
Alright, so, the technique that we are going to
apply to solve this problem is unit access T.
As the name suggests, this technique is an
extension of the unit semantic segmentation
architecture. Therefore, the unit access T has two
components the unit architecture itself and its
extension let us discuss the two components one by
one. So, the first component is the unit network
unit is a network that is used for semantic
segmentation. In the problem of semantic
segmentation, we are required to segment a region
of interest from a given image. For instance,
in an image captured by a self driving car, we are
required to segment the cars that are present in
the image and the road that is present in the
image. We can do so, by highlighting them with
different colors. The unit architecture is similar
to other semantic segmentation architectures where
we have an encoder part of the network and
we have the decoder part of the network.
The encoder part down samples the image
deriving different visual features in the
image and then we have the decoder part which
up samples the image and returns us the output
apart from the information derived
from the decoder part itself,
the decoder uses information from the encoder part
using skip connections as we can see over here.
Initially, unit architecture was devised
for biomedical image segmentation. However,
its use cases applies to other domains as well
for instance in our case self driving cars
unit forms the basic architecture for this
technique. Now, let us discuss the Xs D are
the extension part of the unit network. The
extension part of the technique is that we make
use of what are called spatial transformers. So,
before discussing what are spatial transformers,
let us discuss the concept of homography. For
instance, we have an object and we take its image
from a camera that is placed over here, we change
the camera position as well as its orientation to
something over here. And we take the image again,
the transformation between these two images is
what is called homography. In mathematical terms,
homography is a simple matrix multiplication.
A cool application of mammography is that if
we know the homography matrix that converts
from one image plane to other image plane, then
from a single image, we can directly compute
how that object would look like in a separate
image plane without even taking a different
picture. However, in application, we would require
those image planes to be close to each other.
In general, the transformation need not be that
complex, they can be as simple as translating
the camera plane or even rotating the
camera plane at a given fixed point.
For instance, given this image, we are rotating
the image plane by approximately 15 degrees.
Not theoretically, it would seem that we can
simply take an image x, multiply it by homography
matrix H and get the final resulting image at x.
However, it is not that simple. In simple terms,
homography is a simple transformation that map's
pixels from one image to another image. Hence,
what we would have is this image pixel mapped
to some image pixel in this image over here.
On doing this matrix multiplication, it is easy
to observe that the output x x is not going to
output integer values. What this means is that a
given pixel over here is going to map to a number
of different pixels over here. Hence, in order to
apply this transformation, we are going to have
a lot of different average calculations made
Making the final image look not really good.
Hence, a solution to this is to do
an inverse homography calculation
what that means, instead of computing a
transformation that goes from input to output,
we instead calculate a transformation that
goes from the output pixel to the input pixels.
For instance, this output pixel over here is going
to map to the input image in a rotated fashion
something like this over here, we calculate an
average of the surrounding pixels in the input
image. For instance, this pixel is going to map
to surrounding these four pixels over here. Hence,
we are going to calculate their weighted average
pixel values to derive the value of this pixel.
This weighted average is calculated using
a technique called by linear interpolation.
The weighted average is taken with respect to the
distance from the surrounding pixels. In place
of by linear interpolation, we can apply other
different techniques like linear interpolation or
nearest neighbors as well. However, for spatial
transformers by linear interpolation is the choice
due to its differentiated by nature. So, having
understood this complete process of homography,
let us discuss the use of this
homography. In a spatial transformer.
Spatial transformer is an extension module
that can be applied to any convolution network.
This enables the convolution network to also learn
the different spatial properties that are present
in the dataset. The spatial transformer learns
the different parameters of the homography metrics
in order to aid the convolution network. In the
same example, if we have an object over here,
and we take its image from this point, and let us
assume for some reason, the CNN architecture is
not able to classify this object accurately,
how spatial transformers are going to help
the spatial transformers are going to
learn the homography matrix parameters
in such a way that they present an image to the
CNN from a different point, so that the CNN is
able to classify that object more accurately. So
having understood what is a spatial transformer,
and how it helps, let us see how we apply this
to a unit xs D technique. For the unit accessory
technique, we are not going to learn
the parameters of the homography matrix.
Instead, we are going to provide the spatial
transformers with a fixed homography matrix.
So where do we get these homography parameters.
Since homography, is a general application,
we can also apply this to our self driving cars
scenario as well. For instance, given this image
from a right facing camera, we can easily derive
a homography that maps from this right camera to
a virtual camera that is present at the top. We
can do this for all the four cameras and derive
a top view of the environment. In this way,
we will easily get the homography parameters.
This technique of deriving the top view from
these given images is also called inverse
perspective mapping. But there's a natural
question to ask why we apply complex network
architectures like unit access T, whereas we can
solve our problem using simple homography ease.
The answer to this is the top view homography or
inverse perspective mapping makes an assumption
that the world around these cameras is flat. We
can easily observe that this assumption does not
hold true in any case whatsoever. The cars the
trucks, pedestrians and the different monuments,
they have considerable height in order for
the inverse perspective mapping to work.
Although we can get a top view of the environment
by applying and inverse perspective mapping,
however, the results that we get from
that technique are not really accurate
and useful for our task. Hence, we need
such complex architectures like unit SST
Alright, so the two components are unit access D
are not discussed. Now let us see how these two
components combine to give the final architecture.
For this network, we are going to have four inputs
for the four different images that we have
as you can see over here, we are going to
have a similar encoder network for each of these
four images as can be seen from the red lines.
For the decoder, we again
have similar architecture,
however, there is a single pipeline that gives us
the final output. These skip connections over here
are what makes use of spatial transformers. These
four feature maps at different levels are combined
using spatial transformers. Each feature is first
pass through a spatial transformer. And then these
different features are combined. This combination
is then fed through the skip connection.
And this is done similarly for
each level of the architecture.
Alright, so this is it for the technical
discussion of unit SSD. Now, let us have
a brief look at the implementation and the
results that we get from training this network.
Alright, so the link to this implementation
would be provided in the description box below.
In the first section, we have implemented the
different utility functions like load image,
and one hot conversion of the input image.
In simple terms, what one hot encoding means,
given a semantic segmented input that has various
different colors, we convert that RGB image into
a 3d matrix that contains a sparse representation
of the different classes. This representation is
helpful for the machine learning model to learn
and understand the data. In the next section,
we have the different configuration parameters.
One thing to note is that there are certain
changes that have been applied to these parameters
in order to obey the constraints that are provided
by us on Kaggle the image shape has been reduced
in order to get a faster learning curve. The batch
size has also been increased in order to get the
same results. Also, the algorithm is only trained
for a total of 40 epochs, whereas you would have
required to train 400 epochs. In this next section
we have the different data loader functions that
load the data for our machine learning model.
In this next section, we define the different
network architecture. First we define the
spatial transformer. Next we implement unit
along with the spatial transformer extension.
And finally, we train the network. Now let us
have a look at the final output predictions.
Just like before, we have images from
the four cameras on the self driving car,
the front rear left and right this next image
is the output prediction generated by our model.
And the next image is the ground
truth bird's eye view image.
As we can see the model has learned to some
extent to represent the bird's eye view image.
However, there is some slight
noise that is present in the output
let us have a look at other images as well.
Overall, we can say the model has learned
a representation of bird's eye view image,
but it would require more training
to converge to more better results.
Alright, so this is all that we had to
discuss for this unit access the technique.
Congratulations on completing the course
we together did seven different projects
and got to learn more about the different concepts
applied to perception in self driving cars.
We did three projects related to 2d and then
did four projects that were related to 3d.
In order to follow up with
this course. I recommend
that you go over different datasets apart
from the ones discussed in this course,
read and implement new research papers related to
perception for self driving cars. Or you can jump
due and learn more about different modules for
a self driving car like localization or motion
planning. As far as computer vision is concerned,
you can also try out different other projects
like similarity learning, image captioning and
generative modeling. This is all that we had to
discuss for this course. And I will see you in
another video or another course till then bye